for decades this region in West Texas
has been pummeled with droughts
reservoirs and lakes often sit almost
empty grass has gone Brown
and crops are struggling last rain was
in October we went through all the
winter months with no rain our cotton as
you can see none of it's came up every
acre of our cotton just imagined on bare
soil that's bone dry
In the Heat of Texas things can
sometimes look bleak but what if I told
you that there's a way to help fix this
problem
by flying into the clouds and making
them rain
[Music]
this graph shows Texas droughts over the
past Thousand Years all of these dips
below this line represent a severe
drought and Texas has a long history of
them this light blue section is data
from tree ring observations the dark
blue is modern data from the past
hundred years and it suggests that the
droughts are becoming hotter and more
severe that has a lot to do with climate
change the average temperature in Texas
has increased by about 1.5 degrees
Fahrenheit since the early 1900s and the
rate of increase is going up
record-breaking temperatures record heat
100 plus Degree Days dangerous heat
already turning his store
[Music]
this year Texas has already hit record
temperatures including here in the west
Texas city of San Angelo some farmers in
this area of Texas deny that human
activity is driving climate change but
they all agree on one thing
things are definitely getting worse
this year is definitely different
earlier hotter or ready drier
jeans Acres of bare cotton fields are
some of the clearest proof of the damage
a drought can cause when it's this dry
we just can't pump enough water to get
that crop growing looking out here
that's none of these Acres will be
harvested
usually rain is absorbed into the ground
plants and crops soak up the water they
need and the rest keeps the soil moist
fills up the aquifers and the runoff
fills up the Lakes eventually
evaporation and plant transpiration
release water back into the atmosphere
where it becomes precipitation again
this is the water cycle that keeps us
alive when temperatures are unusually
warm this cycle is disrupted plants hold
on to their water and transpire less and
evaporation from the ground happens too
fast
together they destabilize a cycle and
prolong the lack of rain
and while this lack of rain hurts
everyone it's farmers who feel it the
most
some days it is pretty disheartening you
look at that
[Music]
we always want to be a farmer you want
to grow a good crop you want to plant it
want to get it up we want to grow it
nothing more beautiful than
waste high cotton but uh
it's not going to happen and we know
that living here that it doesn't always
happen
but it is a struggle
[Music]
but there is a technology that can help
protect this cycle it's called cloud
seeding and it involves getting the
clouds to make more rain
so I visited the west Texas weather
modification Association one of many
organizations around the world that
practice cloud seeding and so basically
what you do in the sky is you're kind of
coaxing the cloud to produce more rain
exactly right we're just getting more
rain out of a cloud than would otherwise
be the case on stormy days Pilots load
up small planes with these Special
flares full of chemicals like silver
iodide and fly to the edge of
thunderstorms to launch the flares into
the clouds
foreign
thunderstorm clouds are full of droplets
of super cool liquid water meaning they
are in freezing temperatures but they
are still liquid these drops are too
small to freeze and too small to merge
they are also too light for Gravity to
pull them down so they just float around
in the cloud enter silver iodide the
silver iodide particles mimic ice
crystals and provide the scaffolding of
sorts for ice to form that ice then
grows very efficiently by consuming the
super cool liquid drops usually after
about 20 minutes they grow large enough
and fall out of the cloud as
precipitation
more rain means Fuller lakes rivers and
aquifers then consistently the hope is
that cloud seeding can help Bank water
this keeps the soil wet longer and can
help protect the water cycle when things
get really dry during a drought
when we visited Texas there were no
thunderstorms in the forecast but local
Pilots Derek and Tanner took us up into
the sky for a practice run so we could
see the process up close
we're ready when you are ready
oh
that is shooting out all the silver
iodized it's going into the clouds
so that trail is literally the chemicals
that there's no chemicals coming out
all right let's uh let's head RGB
we're gonna be late
[Applause]
cloud seating technology has been around
since the 1940s but proving the effects
of cloud seeding on the ground has been
a struggle one of the biggest challenges
in weather modification is the ability
to show statistically that it works how
do we know that a cloud wasn't already
going to do what it did on a day-to-day
basis it's hard to see that but over a
20-year span where we have thousands of
seated clouds compared to unseated
clouds we're seeing increases of 15
percent other cloud seeding programs
have also shown increases in rainfall of
about 15 percent but have failed to meet
the standards of the scientific
community
the researchers they would probably
prefer that we went to this Cloud rolled
dice all right it's odd so let's move on
to this Cloud it's an even let's see
that we're not able to do that our
programs expect every cloud to be seated
so we're not able to do the randomized
seating that that the scientific
Community would like to see
but today tests using clouds in snowy
mountains are providing further evidence
that cloud seeding Works in a 2017 study
in Idaho radar footage captured ice
crystals forming in the same pattern the
cloud seeding airplane was flown in and
the snowfall was then tracked on the
ground
a lot of variables change from the
mountains of Idaho to the flats of Texas
and thunderstorms are shorter smaller
and change faster than snowstorms still
the experiment in Idaho has added to a
growing body of evidence that cloud
seeding works
so far researchers have seen few
downsides most studies like this one
conducted in Wyoming in 2014 have found
negligible environmental impact
and the cost of flying up a pilot with
flares is relatively low especially
compared to the value of water in West
Texas the program is funded by local
water districts and costs just a few
cents an acre but even if this
technology works it only works when
there's already rain in the forecast if
we were able to create a cloud out of
nowhere there would be no drought so
this is definitely rain enhancement
Gene's Farm is right outside the cloud
seating program's Target area but he
wants in can you prove that it helps or
it doesn't I don't know but it's better
than nothing you can't just sit on your
hands to make more rain you know cloud
seating is really the only thing out
there I brought some of those ideas back
here to our coffee shop talking with the
guys some of the older farmers and
there's some negativity there but uh
definitely I think we need to revisit
that and
it may be time to have the water
the cloud seeding man come in and give
us a program out here on the flats
opposition to cloud seating isn't new in
New Mexico for instance some locals have
expressed concerns over environmental
safety and funding but farmers in the
area would have to wait for the next
rainy season to start seeing results
during the wet years
it is very important for us and it's
easy to get relaxed during wet years but
it's very important for us to stay on
our game and be aggressive during those
wet Seasons because that's when we Bank
our water so we get extra recharge into
our aquifer so we get runoff in the
lakes rivers and reservoirs
around the world droughts are on the
rise the UN predicts three quarters of
the world's population will be impacted
by a drought by 2050. in places like
China Europe Australia India where
droughts are already worsening cloud
seeding programs are in full swing
as cloud seeding gains traction we'll
learn more about what it can and can't
do for us but as I leave the sweltering
heat of Texas I can't help but think
that to really lessen the damage caused
by droughts we need climate change
mitigation that means reducing emissions
to control the temperature to protect
our water cycle as a whole
foreign
[Music]
[Music]